hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys I'm
seven we're gonna check out from I'm
Dante many people acid i watch this his
big announcement reveal let's find out
what this is all about from the man who
bought you the roast the time around hey
hilarious side-splitting comedy video
he's Cusco followed by a blow for of
copycats let's compare out to you by the
man who thought he can get away with
doing a roast from his garage he's here
to unveil his big announcement to the
world uh ladies and gentlemen I give you
me now get ready for your stomach's to
hurt because I'm dropping a trailer for
the rest of ryan right oh it's gonna be
featuring somebody that that's amazing
with trailers you know might known from
a honest trailers I'm talking about John
Bailey what yes
I hope you guys are all ready for that
trailer it will be coming sometime next
week yeah Nana Nana boo boo stick your
head in doo last time it was a tyro
Magnus roast okay yeah but like he got
someone from honest trailers to dis you
that would be pretty cool I mean that
would really hurt my feelings now that
I'm thinking about I'm like oh man
because i really respect honest trailers
and they're like one of my top three
favorite channels well I don't know why
I pulled that one off but good for you
way lets just hear that part again real
fast it's gonna be featuring somebody
that that's amazing with trailers you
know might know him from a honest
trailers I'm talking about John Bailey
yes
I hope you guys are all ready for that
trailer it will be coming okay I guess
he's getting him yeah I don't care
[ __ ] and told me as much as you want
as long as you got to be more attention
okay with that I mean if you got like
Emma Watson to just me I'd [ __ ] love
that [ __ ] man hmm what sorry I brought
it up wow you brought it up for sure by
bringing up her name well I am are you
happy yeah very happy now okay yeah no
I'm cool with him doing a roast about me
um I think that'd be fun I would fire
back um with real wit though like I'm
gonna study every one of his videos you
better watch out all day I'll get all
the rejects to say something my dad
watch out Dante's guess what I got
quantity over quality so get ready
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out salamander Sally's channel on
the Sally channel what the and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine periscope you were saying something
that again never seeing something no
yeah I wasn't I wasn't every time you
look at my lips I think you want to kiss
me now that's not nice I felt looking
who goes oh n yeah